[MUSIC]
Welcome to the Stanford MBA session
on your journey and preparing for
career off the beaten path.
My name is Lisa Giannangeli and
I'm a director of MBA admissions at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Or the GSB,
as we affectionately referred to it.
I'm also an alumna of the program as well.
And I'm delighted to be joined by some
of my fellow alumni today who will share
a bit more about their experiences.
But here's what to expect
from today's session.
We'll talk a little bit about
where your journey might take you,
you'll have an opportunity
to meet our panelists.
I'll start us off with a little bit of
questions and answers to get us going.
And then we really want to spend some
time answering your questions as well.
So at any point, again, feel free to
submit your questions in that Q&A box.
If you see a question that someone else
has asked that you also particularly like,
you can click on that little thumbs up
symbol which will help vote that up
to the top.
And we'll have about 55
minutes together today.
And hopefully this is just
a wonderful opportunity for
you to engage with our community.
And to learn a little bit more about
the Stanford GSB experience and
how it might enrich your professional
opportunities going forward.
So let's talk a little bit about
where your journey will take you.
So here you see some recent
stats from our class of 2020.
91% of our students had job offers
three months after graduation.
445 different organizations
hired our MBA students for
either summer or full time opportunities.
And 71% of our students were making
a career pivot, whether it was an industry
function, and/or location, or
some combination of those three.
Now oftentimes when we think of MBAs,
we think of some of those
typical post MBA industries, so
finance, technology, consulting.
But I think one of the wonderful things
about this session in particular is that
it really highlights how
flexible an MBA education is.
And how can really take you in
a number of different directions.
You'll note in the class of 2020,
19% of our students immediately went into
socially responsible roles,
18% started new ventures.
And for the sixth consecutive year,
we have record high compensation
within the MBA market.
So we're also very, very proud of that.
But let's take a moment now
to meet some of our alumni.
Some folks whose paths have led them to
sort of job opportunities or professional
opportunities that are sort of off
the beaten path for our MBA students.
We'll have each of our panelists
briefly introduce themselves, Jackie,
would you like to get us started?
>> Yeah, happy to.
The GSB was an amazing experience.
And prior to grad school, I worked in
philanthropy and social entrepreneurship.
I ran a couple different nonprofits.
And then during graduate school I got
really passionate about women's sexual
health market.
And how to use business to create
more equity related to sexual health.
So for the first year or so business
school I explored investing, I worked in
venture capital, and interned in impact
investing in the sexual health market.
And was interested in
starting a fund at first.
And then I became really passionate
about discrimination and advertising
where a lot of entrepreneurs couldn't
advertise women's health products.
Because they're being misclassified as
adult products despite mass ads being
allowed for erectile dysfunction.
So I decided to create a nonprofit
that does advocacy and
policy work to change tech policies.
But I'll briefly also mentioned that
what's been amazing about the GSB is that
it also creates opportunities to try
completely different areas with a lot of
amazing support.
So since grad school,
I've also been delving into investigative
journalism writing, and documentary.
And also a lot of law in my work,
which it's all been a helpful
platform to try new areas.
>> Great, and Yiming,
if you want to continue us, continue on.
>> Okay, hi everyone,
my name is the Yiming Mah,
and I was graduated in class of 2018.
I'm Chinese Canadian.
And after undergrad I spent two years
at McKinsey at the New York office
in corporate finance.
And then moved to London where I spent
two years investing in school chains.
And for profit education technology
companies out of South Africa and
parts of Southeast Asia as well.
So, the year before GSB,
I actually took a bit of time and
that's where I started writing again.
It rekindled kind of my love for something
that I never really thought was possible
being a first generation immigrant.
And at GSB I looked at just
broadening my horizons and
learning about what creative
fields might look like.
And so, specifically industry
wise I looked into media and
summered at Sony out of LA.
And then after graduation I joined
the Bertelsmann Leadership
Development Programme.
Every year, Bertelsmann,
which owns Penguin Random House,
the world's largest publisher.
Takes about two to three people who
do this leadership rotation program.
And so I had the opportunity
to work across Berlin,
in Germany then moved to New York as
part of the main publishing office.
And then I was the first
one to go into Toronto and
work out of the Canadian office.
So I had a great experience there and
really learned a lot about this
black box of publishing that
still a mystery to most writers.
And decided partly due to
COVID to take some time and
actually complete my first novel.
And so that's something I'm in
the process of finalizing at the moment.
And it's really a period of transition
where I'm looking to get back into
the workforce.
But at the same time, finalize the draft
and prepare that for submission.
So it's really been a one man startup for
the last two years on this front.
And I'm excited to continue
along that journey but
also move back into
the business field as well.
>> And Jack, over to you.
>> Sure, so my background before going to
school, I'm from the Midwest originally,
had done McKenzie and
private equity after undergrad.
So in that sense I was kind of
down the middle of the fairway,
there were a couple things
made me a little different.
As I was applying one, I had done
a stint in politics in Chicago, so
I work for the mayor in Chicago.
And then my wife and I were playing
together and she had a way cooler and
more interesting background.
So we ended up somehow both getting in,
which was amazing, and
attended it together.
And I think when I was at school,
I was looking to sort of zoom out and
decide from my three jobs,
what I liked and what I didn't.
So sort of decide what I
wanted to do long term.
And work on moving from sort of entry
level roles in each position to more of
a leadership or manager role.
And I happened to catch
that entrepreneurial bug,
which is common at Stanford.
And started spending more and
more time with the classmate working
on business ideas and agriculture.
And ended up founding and running a kind
of hybrid investor, and operator, and
sustainable farming.
We have farms up and
down California, in Arizona.
So excited to meet everybody today and
tell you how awesome our
experience was it at Stanford.
>> And Sam.
>> Hi everybody, Sam I was very much
on the fence about getting an MBA,
I had worked for
the Obama campaign in 2012.
After two years of consulting and
it was the best thing I ever did,
loved it thought I wanted to work in
public sector for the rest of my life.
So went to went to Stanford Law School,
thinking that I would do that, and
law school is very much,
it's great in many ways, but
it's very much an on the beaten
track kind of place.
And I realized pretty soon I didn't
want to be on that track, and so
I ended up applying to the GSB,
which I never thought I would do.
And did a joint degree and it ended up
that the business school was far and
away the sort of more impactful and
meaningful and empowering part of that.
So I used to really explore, I didn't
really know what I wanted to do coming in,
and I ended up after two years and thanks
to a ton of help from classmates and
professors and staff.
Ended up starting a public
interest law firm.
So, like Jack sort of,
in some ways that is a common path,
got the entrepreneurship bug started a for
profit venture back startup.
But we're also a licensed law firm or
a B Corp and
almost all our work is helping disabled
people get government benefits.
And we just hired our 20th employee,
and I could never have done it without
paying for itself, excited to share.
>> Emilie, over to you.
>> Hi, I'm Emilie Eliason,
I'm an Oz tix grad at the GSB and
prior to the GSB I worked in
the early days of digital marketing.
I worked for
a small market research firm as well.
And I thought I would stay in the digital
world, I did my internship at Yahoo, but
ended up taking a kind of a more
traditional path and brands.
Marketing, working for Clorox after
graduation, and I love the work but
I'm working mostly on the toilet products
and wondered if I could apply my
skills for something that I had
a little bit more interest in.
And actually through a great program
that the GSB offers, call it
alumni consulting groups and was able to
get introduced into the wine industry.
And I've been doing that now for
about the past 15 years.
So I'm currently the general manager
of a company called Geodesy wine and
I have three different kind of very
different components of my job.
I do farming.
I do wine marketing and
then I also do some philanthropy, so,
I oversee about four ranches,
1000 acres, we mostly sell grapes.
Produce and sell grapes, I have started
a new wine brand called Geodesy.
And the sole purpose of the wine brand
is to fund a women's leadership and
development program for young people who
want to have careers in agriculture.
So I run the foundation and the program
is about kind of the philanthropy part.
And certainly all those different
things together never ever would have
been able to do or construct or figure
out without all the great skills and
experience I got out of the GSB.
>> Then rounding out the panel, Rebecca,
would you like to introduce yourself?
>> Everyone, it's so fun to hear all these
different, really wonderful stories.
I'm Rebecca and I am GSB class of 2005 and
I grew up in the Sierra
foothills on a campground.
And was a whitewater rafting guide and
went for
the first time to the east coast for
college and
then moved to New York City after
college as a choral fellow.
And that's where I really, I would say,
became an urbanist and came to love
the connection of people in place in an
urban environment, not just on the river.
And I worked in urban development there
for a few years and then came back to
California what I thought was my permanent
trip home to California for the GSB.
And had an amazing two years which
we'll talk more about during Q&A.
I spent my summer at the White House
Office of Management and Budget.
I'd been working a lot with local
governments in New York City and
Charlotte, across the eastern seaboard,
really and I wanted to see what community
development policy looks like at
more of the 30,000 foot level.
Then decided that was way
too ivory tower for me, and
I needed to get more into the numbers.
And so I went to Goldman Sachs for
seven years in public sector and
infrastructure banking in New York and
then came back to San Francisco.
And left there to work for
Mayor Ed Lee in San Francisco on
public private partnerships and
infrastructure related financing
initially in San Francisco.
Rapidly pivoted to what became the most
important issue when I was there,
which was housing.
I called up a lot of GSB classmates,
to say, tell me everything you know about
real estate, despite what it says here,
my first job wasn't really in real estate.
And that's where I founded and then
spun off the housing accelerator fund,
which is the nonprofit lending
investing fund that I run now and
we invest in affordable housing.
Preservation and
production in the Bay Area.
>> Great, well, a wonderful and
eclectic group of panelists here, so
again to our audience members, and
feel free to go to that Q&A box.
And type in any questions that you
would like to ask our panelists,
I'll get us started though
with a handful of questions.
And let's see the first question
I'll pose to Rebecca and
Yiming, why an MBA and
why specifically Stanford?
Rebecca, would you like to start?
>> Sure, and so I would say why an MBA,
I went to undergraduate at Brown,
which I think I share that
with another panelists.
Yeah, and you have full freedom
which is kind of scary at Brown,
there's no set majors
there's no core curriculum.
And I didn't take an econ math
investing fine, like none of it,
none of those things,
I was fully focused on public health,
developing the burden of disease
in developing countries.
And in my first job working in urban
development and public private
partnerships, things like Brooklyn Bridge
Park, and the Highline in New York City.
I realized pretty quickly that
in order to get things done that
I really cared about at the local level,
having more of that finance,
real estate and negotiations,
business [LAUGH].
And skill set was really important but
I knew that the way I love
to learn is very relationship focused and
it's a lot about the people and
I really care a lot about leadership and
community.
And so those two things seemed
like that led me to an MBA.
I knew that I wanted to be in California,
place is really important
to me at Stanford.
I knew I wanted to be in the Bay area and
so that was a big driver behind Stanford,
I wanted to be in the place
where I wanted to put in routes.
And I also really loved the public
management program at Stanford because
that intersection between the public and
private sectors has been a big focus for
me.
>> Yiming, how about you?
>> Yeah,
I'll start off with my undergrad as well.
I went to school in Canada,
which is relatively uncommon, but
I'm a Canadian and my school program
was actually based a lot on.
Harvard case study method.
So my university,
the Richard Ivey School of Business,
is actually the second largest producer of
case studies in the world behind Harvard.
So it's exactly the opposite of Brown in
many ways, right, what Rebecca was saying.
We didn't have that much flexibility.
All of our class were taught
[INAUDIBLE] cases, and
we didn't have that choice because
it started really in the third year.
And I knew I wanted to go back to
school again and broaden my horizons.
And out of all the programs, it was clear
to me that Stanford was the best for me.
And I'll get into that a little bit later.
But the big thing for me at the time
was that it was the right time.
I had spent two years in
New York out of McKinsey.
So I had gotten that experience already,
and I was honestly a little bit burnt out.
I had been leading these
impact investments.
And I think I went to travel across
30 countries in two years or
something ridiculous like that.
I was flying all over, spending a lot of
time in parts of Africa looking at deals.
And I knew that, okay, this feels like the
right time to go back to school, recharge,
and learn a lot of different things,
and consider if I do want to pivot.
And, specifically,
I was in London at the time and
I wanted to make that transition back
to North America where my family is.
Tactically my GMATs, I scored well,
but they were about to expire.
Four years had passed,
and so this was the year.
And when I looked at schools, Stanford,
was just clearly the one
that I was interested in.
I'd work with founders for
a couple of years.
I had that entrepreneurial itch and
still really wanted to build something.
And at the time because I
was investing in education,
there was a dual education MBA
program that I was considering.
I knew that there was
a lot of flexibility or
opportunities to take
classes across the street.
Culture wise was this focus on empathy and
being able to work on the soft
skills in addition to the hard skills,
it was a bit of a no brainer.
So out of all the schools I applied to,
by far Stanford was the one
that I was excited to join.
>> Anyone else have thoughts, please
feel free to chime in at any point too.
Well, I'll go to the next question here,
and maybe Jackie you can start us off.
And Rebecca, if you have comments, or
Emily as well, feel free to chime in.
But were there any academic courses at
Stanford that kind of forced you to
stretch yourself in new ways or
maybe helped enable your success today?
Jackie, do you want to get us started?
>> Yeah, definitely,
one of the most helpful courses for
me was a winning writing course.
Stanford has a lecturer who for 35 years,
he's been an editor with the New York
Times, and he's helped between 10 and
12 different Pulitzer Prize
winning articles.
And we have him as, not just
a teacher of our writing class, but
as an incredible mentor and friend.
He really gets to know the students.
And so I took his class and he sent an
op-ed that I wrote to the New York Times,
which ended up being published a week or
two after I graduated.
And that was about discrimination toward
women sexual wellness businesses.
He also brought Nick Kristoff to our
class and set up a call between me and
one of the most famous journalists,
which was incredible.
And the faculty really
want to help you succeed.
So he's right now helping as
a recommender on a fellowship.
So I loved that course.
I also really liked, we have a professor
named Laura Arriaga Andreessen who created
a women in leadership course and
has a longtime philanthropy course.
But outside of her class,
she would have dinners at her house with
Arianna Huffington and Darren Walker.
Had a guest at every week
at her house at some point,
because she was such an incredible mentor.
The other two quickly I'll mention is I
really liked that there were two classes
about impact investing that I took.
And then we also had a class about how to
negotiate term sheets as an angel investor
or venture capitalist, which I think for
classmates that were going to go work at
a VC firm, might have been less relevant.
But for those that wanted to do
more entrepreneurial investing,
the term sheet classes
mattered in particular.
And the faculty would normally charge
thousands of dollars an hour as
a consultant, but you got to have his
office hours for free as a student, or
included in tuition.
>> Rebecca, over to you, are there any
academic experiences that stand out?
>> So, I was in the inaugural class for
a class that's still going and
has grown called designing for
extreme affordability.
And that was basically,
we were partnered with a specific
community-based organization,
in this case it was in Southern India.
And focused over the course of a semester
working with engineering students and
other students across depending
on kind of who came in.
Law students across
the campus on coming up with
a business plan for and
prototyping a water system,
in this case for farmers for
less than $1 a day.
And I still think about that in
launching the housing accelerator fund.
And it was before design
thinking was like so
much the thing and
rapid iterations and fail fast.
It was very early edge, which I think you
often get, which is so awesome at the GSB.
The earliest edge thinking and
approach to how do we think and
create things and work together across
different sectors in different ways?
And so I loved that class and
it will definitely echo what Jackie said
about the access overall to
the professors, and the faculty dinners.
I have a beloved professor, Jim Van Horn,
who taught corporate finance for
decades, which is another
favorite class of mine.
I still think about it every board that
I sit on when I actually understand how
the income statement and
the cash flow statement and
the balance sheet all fit together.
I thank Jim Van Horn for that.
And especially my running
my own organization now.
And we still send each other
cards every holiday season and
he writes a lot in them.
So I think those kinds of
connections that you can build
with the professors were
is really a highlight also.
>> Emily, how about you, anything that
stood out from an academic class or
experience?
>> All of those, I had some commonalities
with what Jackie and Rebecca had said and
completely agree.
The only one that I would add I found
incredibly impactful was Touchy Feely.
So, at the GSB, we have a course
that is nicknamed Touchy Feely.
It's called interpersonal dynamics.
And, in large part, it's kind of group
therapy with a bunch of MBA students,
which is kind of scary.
And, it tends to be one of the most
impactful classes that folks have.
I think, for me, Stanford,
it was great to have so
many classes where there were nuts and
bolts learning, right?
Learning finance, similar to Rebecca,
I have a liberal arts background.
So that was really important for
me to get some of that experience,
understanding logistics,
understanding modeling and marketing.
But ultimately, I think Stanford does
such a good job developing leaders, and
that's really what that class is about.
It's kind hard to describe, but
it is one that I think a lot of
people get something out of.
It's very unique to Stanford.
And that was one that I got a lot out of.
And honestly every day, every week,
there's something that comes up
that I learned in Touchy Feely.
All right, this next question I'll
pose to Jack then send over to Yuning.
Were there any Stanford clubs or
extracurricular activities that you
participated in that maybe helped you
explore or think about new career paths or
interests that you had.
Jack maybe starting with you?
>> Yeah, I came in with kind of a big
company background in consulting in
private equity firm and even in politics
I worked for a large organization.
And I was really interested in exploring,
doing something again in politics,
so I spent some time in
the government politics group.
Like for example, we went and knocked on
doors in Nevada, which was really cool.
I also spent some time in the
entrepreneurship-type clubs in food and
ag, where I ended up working.
And I think that sort of
morphed over time into more and
more just the informal extracurricular
that's very common of working on.
Whether it's some kind of side project
that's professional in nature, or
starting a company or things like that,
that many of my classmates were
doing simultaneous with school.
And I think the club sort of
provided the foundation for
that where you're meeting other
people that have shared interests.
And then, my experience was over the two
years, it became more and more real and
more and more time-intensive and
kind of led into what I'm doing now.
So the clubs were super helpful for
me to just explore spaces that I didn't
know as well or
find people with shared interests.
And then the other extracurricular
thing I was going to mention is,
maybe this is outside of
the scope of this question, but
we did a few GSTs and other travel,
that were just massively important for
us to feel a closer connection
with some of our classmates.
I think we sort of met everyone
quickly and it's 400 people on
[INAUDIBLE] when you get there and
it can be a little overwhelming.
But then traveling for a couple of
weeks with a smaller group of 10 or
20 really forged some
bonds that my wife and
I still talk to the people that we
went to some of these trips with.
So I don't know that that's quite in
the scope of extracurriculars, but
it was really important to our experience.
>> Yeah, those global study trips I
think are highlights for many students,
Yuning over to you.
>> Yeah, so I was involved in our arts,
media, and entertainment club.
I ended up organizing and leading
the Future of Media conference that we
have every year, my first year,
and moderating some panels on it.
So Scooter Braun came during our year,
who's the main agent for Justin Bieber,
and honestly I learned way more about
how he kind of fell out of favor and
then came back to the roast
than I ever thought I would.
But in addition to clubs, I ended up
attending a ton of talks throughout
campus, so not just at the GSB,
but often in other fields.
So, in particular, whenever authors came
like George Saunders, Anthony Joyer,
I had the chance to listen to these people
who never came to Canada, in particular,
and got to meet some of them as well.
And some of those conversations I had and
advice I got, it made me more confident
to ultimately invest in myself and
invest in this dream that I always had.
And then one other thing that I'd add in
terms of extracurriculars, it was related
to a course I took in anthropology and
psychiatry as part of Stanford.
But I ended up spending eight
weeks working with formerly
homeless adults in San Mateo,
on improv therapy.
And so every week we'd carpool over and
work with these adults who were in various
shapes in terms of their mental health and
it was a really,
really impactful experience for me.
And I was able to apply a lot of what
I learned, not just in that class but
from GSB,
to trying to connect with these people and
something I always bring with me.
>> Thank you, this next question,
Sam, I'll have you kick it off and
then maybe we'll go over to Jackie next.
But starting with you, Sam, how did you
find career support at the Stanford GSB?
Did you leverage the Career Management
Center or any of our other centers,
like our Center for Entrepreneurial
Studies, or Center for Social Innovation,
or other parts of the campus?
How did you kind of go about
that career support process?
>> Yeah, I'll give a big pitch for this.
One thing I didn't expect at the GSB is,
Lisa,
you can correct me if I'm wrong here, but
the GSB's staff to student ratio is crazy.
It felt one to one, it was probably
three or four to one, but there were so
many fantastic people whose job
is to provide student support.
And so those three centers Lisa listed,
I think I used all of them.
Entrepreneurial Studies coordinates
a bunch of really great classes and
does a bunch of research on starting
startups, that I as a lawyer,
read in great detail
before starting a company.
The CMC is amazing, I remember Law School
there was the law firm people who
told you how to get a law firm job, and
there was the public interest people,
who told you how to get one of three
types of public interest jobs.
GSB had 17 different specialties
you could select from.
Grace Yokoi and their team, I remember
I spent way too much time with her just
being, how do I start a startup,
this seems insane.
And she really helped give me
the confidence to do that.
And the general vibe was just such
a choose your own adventure and
they were so great.
The staff have such a reservoir of
knowledge about who good alumni are to
talk to, what good classes are to take,
it really meant a lot to me.
>> Jackie, how about over to you?
>> Yeah, that's amazing, I also used
all of the centers you mentioned.
The Center for Social Innovation was
fantastic, they had a fellowship between
your first and
second years that a lot of students did.
Or a number of students that were
creating social entrepreneurial ventures.
And then they coupled that with
an internship where you could work for
an impact organization,
I worked in impact investing.
And there was tons of funding for
both of those.
I still talk to the staff pretty
regularly from Center for
Social Innovation on mentorship and
they're so helpful.
I also found the peer support incredibly
helpful for career, especially because,
like Lisa mentioned, I think about a fifth
of classmates start their own venture.
And so, while you could absolutely
go into consulting or finance,
I didn't feel any pressure to not do
something entrepreneurial because there
were tons of other students
starting new things.
And so it didn't feel as crazy or scary
since everyone else was bootstrapping or
fundraising.
And then a couple more,
the Career Center was really helpful.
Especially in my first year I was
interested in venture capital and
investing and
I had no investing experience and
income from the nonprofit world.
And the staff was so helpful at
understanding the world of investing and
how to couch your experience in
ways we've got opportunities.
A professor Rob Siegel,
let me work with his venture capital
fund to get exposure during school.
There was also an accelerator called
Start-X where you could get financial aid
and accelerator wraparound support.
And then the last thing I'll mention is
that for people that go into the nonprofit
sector or the public sector, there's loan
forgiveness, which was really helpful.
So I receive, probably $9,000
a year now to repay my loans,
which is super helpful and it's not
taxed and that's also really helpful for
pursuing a career in
social entrepreneurship.
Great, thank you.
This next question, Jack,
I'll maybe have you kick us off.
And then over to Rebecca next and
anyone else who wants to chime in
because I know this was a popular one.
But how have you leveraged
your classmates, alumni,
faculty or
the Stanford network more broadly,
either professionally speaking, right,
or even just personally speaking?
Jack, you want to start us off?
>> Yeah, I mean, I think there's
no way ,like Sam brought up
how powerful the GSB was
in starting his business.
Totally feel the same way
from meeting people in my
industry, to advice on
how to set up my company,
to I've hired a couple
GSBers years behind me.
I think maybe one very tangible
thing is on fundraising.
So, I'd say somewhere between 20 and
50 million of fundraising
has been from Stanford,
either classmates, referrals from
classmates, and other alumni.
So, it's been massively impactful
to me across the board from advice,
to hiring, to fundraising,
to all sorts of ways.
So, there's just no way my business and
my career would be
where it was if I hadn't started
the business while I was at the GSB.
>> Rebecca.
>> I echo all of those things.
And I think, I mean,
I would say in general,
one of the things that maybe attracts
people to Stanford and the GSB but
then is really the seeds are watered when
you're there, is a level of comfort and
openness to reaching out to
your classmates with questions,
for help with the moments when you
need it, to celebrate their successes.
That at a level that I don't
see in many other communities,
especially of that size.
So I think that there's just
a base level of care and
a sense of community that's created and
further cultivated within the class
that really stays with you.
So that it's like, I would say to
any specific situation personal,
professional, that my top five
phone numbers that I would call,
different situation is probably going to
be somebody who I know from the GSB.
And I mean, I have a few great friends
who we're now parents at the same school,
we go for weekly runs together with some
of them, I met my husband at the GSB.
So that's pretty transformational and
I think then specifically,
particularly for
me at career transition points.
That's when I kind of reached out beyond
the closest concentric circle and
tapped into kind of a broader network.
I have a GSB alum from many years from
before my class is on my board right now.
So those kind of moments I
think there's such a deep,
great network and people have
always been really happy to help.
>> I can also chime in if there's time,
and I love everything you shared, Rebecca.
I was going to add there's a program that
student organized at the GSB called Talk,
where students give about a 40 minute
talk about anything in their lives.
And I found that incredibly helpful
because people know what you care about
and can support you the rest of your time.
When I was at the GSB, I knew I wanted
to work in women's sexual wellness and
sex tech, which was absolutely terrifying
for me because it was very stigmatized
area and I didn't know anyone else with
an MBA that was going into that path.
Although now, this year, six Harvard and
Stanford MBAs have reached out to
me that are working in women sex tech,
which is so exciting two years later.
But I felt that it was a great practice
ground to be talking about topics that
terrified me, both in class and
in Talk, and socially, and
really prepared me to get
the confidence to then write.
And there are times out
about those subjects and
now I have no problem talking about them.
Whether it's in a sex discrimination
lawsuit, or a meeting with pretty much,
anyone but
without those two years in a safe space,
I don't know how I would have done that.
And then as an alum, you have so
many WhatsApp groups where we have a
women's founder group that meets monthly.
We have entrepreneur groups,
we have Bay Area groups.
And so
you can always send a question like,
I need a documentary lawyer or I'm
researching competitors in this market,
and everyone will know all
the CEOs in some startup space.
We just had a classmate of mine that
a year out of school successfully
led a shareholder activist approach to
get three sustainability experts on
the board of Exxon Mobil to move Exxon
Mobil to more sustainable directions.
And we had a whole webinar where he talked
to all of our classmates off the record
about their strategies and learning.
So, we're still very much in contact
personally and professionally.
And I also found, as a woman at the GSB
pursuing those areas I shared about,
men were so helpful, classmates connected
me with book publishers because
they thought that you should write
a book about these subjects.
And really, men as well as women were
just incredibly personally supportive in
a way that meant a lot to me.
>> Let's go to some of the questions from
our audience here because we've had a few
submitted now.
So, here's a question from Mike Close.
He says, wow, incredible to hear
all these different experiences.
How do you kind of resist getting caught
up in the more traditional recruiting
tracks in business school, since it can be
difficult to balance your passions with
kind of practicality and finances?
So, anyone want to tackle that one?
>> I could take one stab.
I mean, I think my wife and
I were both going to school, and so
we were both paying a lot of tuition and
I definitely felt that pressure to go,
in my case, what I was concerned is
going back to the firm where I was at,.
And we ended up taking out some loans and
stuff to figure out how to do it.
But I will say Stanford was super helpful.
There's lots of programs that folks
have mentioned about if you're
going into nonprofit, there's extra
incentive sort of to do that, and
lots of fellowships and other things that
I know my classmates took advantage of.
And I just felt financially there
was a lot of resources there to help
figure that out.
And then the culture of my class was so
supportive that just in
terms of the FOMO of what you're
going to do with your career,
I just can't imagine a better place
to do something off the beaten path.
Because so many people were
sort of joining you in that and
that alone helped everyone do what
they were passionate about and
not feel sort of pressured to do what
everyone else was doing basically.
I don't know.
>> Yeah, I'd echo what Jack said and
just add briefly,
there were a bunch of classes and all my
favorite ones at GSB fit this description.
That would have one alum per class period
come in and sort of be a guest speaker,
either to make a case about them,
sometimes they just talk.
And that was really what gave me
confidence because it feels a lot less
crazy once you've met 12 people
who are yeah, I was in your shoes,
two, five, ten years ago and this was
scary and now I did it this is where I am.
I would never have gone off
the beaten track without that.
>> I also had great advice from
a classmate, the first year of GSB.
I was deciding whether to do
interviews for consulting or not but
I knew that I had these other passions and
she had the idea give it six months or
eight months where you just let
yourself fully focus on your
entrepreneurial area and
then assess in six months.
So, you can always apply for
consulting in your second year of MBA but,
set goals for yourself and
then see where you're at at that point.
And six months in, I was so in love with
my work and the goals had all shifted and
they'd all changed but
you knew there was no going back.
So that peer support
was incredibly helpful.
And on the finances, like I mentioned,
the loan forgiveness did help.
There were different fellowships
that you could apply for.
They were obviously competitive, but
a couple of my course mate got I think
$110,000 to create a nonprofit and
there was a few others like that.
Plus the network that you're
getting is incredibly helpful,
like others have mentioned for
their fundraising.
So, there's ways to bolster that
financial opportunities and
I think that it just definitely was
a helpful financial investment.
>> Here's another question,
it says looking back,
what's one thing you would do
differently during your time at the GSB?
Who wants to take that one?
I can try.
I think looking back if it was something
that was really pounded
into us at the GSB.
So it wasn't as if
the opportunities weren't there but
honestly just take more risks.
It is such a risk free
environment in that way.
And it is the opportunity to really
have all of these incredible
people around you, professors,
and alums, and classmates.
And you really have the opportunity to ask
all the dumb questions that you want to
ask and just pick people's brains.
And I think having either saying
that you're a student at the GSB is
a huge door opener for
talking to all sorts of people.
And at the time,
I think it seems a little risky, but
really compared to what things are like in
the real world outside of the GSB bubble.
It's really a great opportunity to take
advantage of having those two years to
just experiment and play around and
just talk to a bunch of different people
to sort of figure out where
it is that you want to go.
Not just in the one or
two years after school but
in the next 5, 10,
15 years because I think and
I know some of the questions that have
come through have asked about pivoting.
And I think, all of us probably
had very clear goals and
ideas of what we were going to do with
the rest of our lives when we applied.
And then a lot of times that changed,
it changed for me while I was at the GSB.
And then it changed again
five years after, and
it changed again five years after that.
And so, it's good to kind of
have all of those skills and
experience from the GSB
that you can draw on.
>> Anything else that you do differently,
anyone at the GSB,
knowing what you know now?
>> I didn't do a global study trip.
I regret that.
[LAUGH] That's already been mentioned.
>> All right, well,
maybe we'll pivot off of what Emily just
was talking about with career pivots.
So we do have some questions here about
all of you mentioned that in one way or
another Stanford GSB has offered an
opportunity to pivot from your old career
path into a new one.
Looking back now, did you know exactly
what you wanted to end up in post MBA kind
of in your current role now and
how you would leverage your
GSB degree to get there?
Or was this sort of an unplanned
serendipitous process that
led you to where you are?
So, does anyone want to talk
about their path or the pivots?
>> I can find,
[LAUGH] you want to go ahead Jackie?
>> No, I can go after you.
>> Okay, so
I wouldn't say necessarily when I went
to GSB I made this pivot that I wanted.
I wanted to become a writer, right.
And to be clear after this last year,
I definitely don't want
to be a full time writer.
And what I will say is that
during GSB it made me more
confident to take risks with my career.
And lot of that has to do with
what Jack and Sam said earlier,
the culture where you saw people
taking these risks, where people felt
comfortable talking about failures, and
failing in startups and coming back.
And so, that's something where, that
made me decide to leave publishing for
a period of time feeling comfortable
that I knew that world well enough that,
if I had something that was worthy of
being published even if maybe there's a 1%
chance of that happening or less.
That I was comfortable taking those
odds on with what I believed I had and
being comfortable that I can
recover if things don't work out.
And so, I think that makes me
more comfortable even now as I'm
transitioning, right?
You could argue, do I even know what
I want to do 20 years from now,
I would honestly say that I wouldn't
be able to predict that at the moment.
But I am comfortable that no matter
what happens based on my track record,
based on my GSB experience,
that I'll be able to bounce back from it.
And I think that's one of the biggest
thing that GSB taught me about pivots is,
yes, there are all the tactical
things that you can do.
There are the steps that you can take like
I won a short story competition run by
The Guardian and by Harper Collins before
I decided to take time off, right,
I actually got into my top tier MFA
program and I'm about halfway done.
It's a remote one so
I can do it during work.
But I build support networks around me.
And so, there are tactical ways in which
GSB helped me think about these things.
So I do things systematically.
But I think the biggest thing is
the courage to be able to do pivots
because you see other people doing it, and
it becomes a little less daunting and
helps you build that confidence.
>> Yeah that's so beautiful,
and for me, there was a lot of
serendipity that led to finding
new passions in grad school.
When I applied I probably
thought I wanted to work for
a foundation in international development.
And now what I'm doing is completely
different because I had several personal
experience in grad school that made me
really passionate about ending sexual
assault and creating a more equal culture.
I started business school and a month
into it the Me Too Movement kicked off.
So all of those things
impacted my career very much.
And then, we were thinking
about a question earlier about,
how to prepare for
a career in a non-traditional path, but
I think it's really about
finding your passions.
And then when people see you doing
what you're passionate about,
others notice your excitement and
possibility and get on board.
I also feel that right now, I am two
years out of GSB, but I'm preparing for
another career pivot where I've
been a social entrepreneur and
founded a couple of nonprofits.
But I realized recently that I'm
really passionate about writing and
that there's a few books
that I want to write.
Some are about.
Law, and I don't have a law degree.
And my professor that I mentioned
earlier from the writing class is really
supportive of me going into
investigative journalism.
And I didn't know any of that.
I didn't really know any
professional writers, so
it's cool hearing your story too, Yiming.
But I've been just putting in place
the foundations to apply to different
fellowships or to try to structure my
finances to figure out how to do writing.
And while I didn't do a ton of writing
other than that class during the GSB,
I definitely echo that you develop
this sense that anything is possible.
You develop the sense that
you can learn new skills.
And that you can dive into a new area.
Because every day at the GSB, it feels
like you can just create whatever you
want to create, because you're seeing
people that are doing that every day.
>> Maybe pivoting off of something that
Jackie said, and I think Yiming you also
talked about it maybe having
some interest in the ed school.
And let's see, we've got Sam who did
the law degree, the joint degree.
How did any of you leverage other
parts of Stanford University,
either taking classes there or connecting
with students or programs or talks?
Talk a little bit more broadly about
your Stanford wide experience.
>> Yeah, just briefly share sort
of the joint degree perspective.
I think there were,
felt like, maybe a quarter or
a fifth of my class were joint degrees and
with a ton of different stuff.
So it's pretty easy once you
get to Stanford to apply to do
a joint degree than
almost any other school.
They all combine neatly with
the business schools, so
you got to take some cross classes.
There's a community of
people who are doing that.
So there was the MD MBAs,
many of them are doctors now.
The JD MBAs, there were PhD MBAs,
which seems insane to me.
But there was a huge mix, and the school
Stanford, I think, much more than most
universities, really is integrated there
in a way that the departments work
together to coordinate stuff and
made the scheduling easy.
And so for
anyone who's considering that just know it
was made really easy to do it and a lot
of folks get to school and then add that.
>> Maybe one last super quick
question in our last minute or so.
What is an experience that you
could have only had at Stanford?
>> I definitely think talk the experience
of hearing hundreds of classmates
share about most vulnerable experiences
of their lives and be so supportive,
for me was transformational.
There's such a culture of vulnerability
at the GSB and of true support.
And I just thought, okay,
my classmates will support all
of my other classmates' topics.
But I really honestly went into my talk
thinking everyone's going to hate me
after I give a talk about female
sexuality for 40 minutes and
actually it was the opposite.
Everyone was so supportive and I felt like
I belonged at the GSB because it really
created a feeling of being accepted.
>> Do want to recognize
that we are getting to,
pardon me, the end of our session here.
And I want to thank all
of our panelists for
sharing your perspectives
today in your various fields.
I think there's just tremendous diversity
represented in your backgrounds and
your experiences.
And again, it just highlights how
wonderfully flexible this MBA degree in
educational experience is.
I also want to thank all of our attendees
today for your interest in Stanford.
We hope that this is just the start
of your Stanford GSB journey and
we definitely invite you to continue it.
One great thing you can do is go to
mystanford.MBA if you haven't been there
already.
You can create a personalized dashboard
by taking a really quick quiz.
And that will help you learn
a little bit more about students or
alumni who might have similar interests
as you do, events that are coming up.
If you start an application,
it'll I'll track your application
progress along the way.
So just lots of wonderful opportunities
to continue to learn more about
Stanford at mystanford.mba.
Again, thank you to everyone for
attending today and
best of luck in your journey for
an off the beaten path career, thank you.
[MUSIC]